so coming on nil hanky-panky my family
and I saw a police officer you spend a
lot of your life doing that and to be
honest with you me I'm not just saying
this it's only in the last sort of six
months and I'm going to ashamed of the
service we have actually like realized
bloody hell like we really depend on the
services like we like as a normal person
I suppose you silly up when you see the
odd robbery or the out fire the odds
strain on the nurses doctors and all
these people you don't realise of just
how much we depend on them but when you
see really big event something that we
have one after the other after the other
lately using [__] are without these
people we'd be really up [__] creek so
I'm you know actually solve a newfound
appreciation for them but over you me I
think I've always had no pictures no I
didn't and I appreciated them but what I
mean is I didn't realize the actual the
seriousness of how badly we need these
people think maybe also and maybe you
can say I think this is what you realize
the good things going well when you
don't realize that's what you have
exactly
so maybe things aren't going so well now
that we know that we have the alien
attachments and things that sort of I
don't know maybe such a silly question
but I'm thinking is it sort of a good
thing for you when people saw on really
away that the police are our own sort of
thing that when you're because we're
more aware of it now to using the latter
sign of the times obvious assignable and
passionately and it's interesting you
say that you become more aware of
actually relying on Elizabeth II police
in particular well that's because of the
nature of those events there isn't them
and the kind of stuff that I did was a
little bit sneakier than that really
and whereas you know the events as you
mentioned in London have been about
things that need to be done things at
police should be doing you know the
police should be protecting communities
and reacting and
educating crimes kind of stuff divide it
it is more debatable whether it's
required I mean I have quite some strike
strong views on that now because it did
please do different things and this what
I'm trying to say and your book is
called good good cop bad war and you
were mainly involved in the war on drugs
is that right yes that's right uh yeah I
was based of 14 years I works undercover
no I my brief was to going to an inner
city and basically cut dry and cash
gangsters mm-hmm and most work from the
bottom up generally so that was that was
my brief episode what how do you start
and how do you get into that because
that's not um I guess maybe is something
intially do you think that I should be
quite cool job and it is quite glamorous
to the mind of a young man yeah because
you're putting on a moustache and you
know got a wink and you know you're
getting to dress up as whatever in your
mosque I think most of the time in life
you'll find whatever you think the job
is is like and I'm talking for all jobs
it's never what it's cracked up to be
and so annual couple allowed to or
policemen who have actually told me like
the kind of regret getting into it now
like the the urge to help people and do
good is still there but the [__] you
have to go through in dealing with
backstabbin and things that goes on in
places like the police or some names
it's more hustle learner to us some
people say well here is how did you feel
when you first walked in as a police
officer that your first early days oh
god I mean I was 19 when the Akhtar
University and I thought what I'm going
to do what were you studying Business
Studies
although you peeed idea cuz my clearance
Alok I got on fine I had absolutely no
interest in Business one though ever so
I could be dropped out and I think that
the what was going on in Manchester at
the time was quite influenced as well
because it was just one big party
it was it was the birth of us
and it was fabulous so ironic that those
who you got recommended to us by Sean
Atwood who was really big into the Dolly
Parton after happening
that was the first name that cooked them
he had when you mentioned that era yeah
many Manchester them is incredible it
really was but I didn't like what would
you you you really raised everything oh
yeah I went to loads of acid house
parties either policeman no no as a
student yeah I stood on on a wooden box
in many a warehouse waving my arms 303's
and skulky so you went a do-gooder like
us in some people make out like that I
guess was a bit of a stereotype about
policemen that they were all bullied at
school and all like basically straight
like as like as I get no I know I was
too basic sort of a bring in fairly
middle class town but not not
particularly well-off grew up in books
another one to college in Manchester but
I mean I didn't last long so I dropped
out as boring as how I realized I wanted
to do something it was you know
different every day so I had planned to
go backpacking around Europe because at
the time that's what adventurous
nineteen year old dead I am sorry I was
mad so yeah yeah interrailing and then
maybe fruit picking that kind of thing
is that this is the idea of how we know
what we don't have that dream we've all
known only I was there and ready to go
and then I saw an advert for the police
in my local newspaper so that'd be
different to today a bit different you
know learn a few few things free
thinking it feels to me though people
and this isn't I kind of wished I'd done
it in a way because of the people seem
to really get a lot of those experiences
and they go backpacking but there's some
people I do know who've gone and then
gone too long and it's almost like now
they just of all you didn't get norm
with life and they just want to put it
on hold yeah and as a youtuber but they
don't yeah but I mean I've been a lucky
buster because when I avoided life it's
just somehow landed on your feet
you know I mean yeah so I think you pick
the sensible option well quite possibly
my life led to code anyway besides do
you really Wow yeah yeah that's quite a
hangers headsman's place ironically like
whether a very non famous criminal Yusef
yeah to fish yeah yeah a real person
optional yeah I was living that BC world
yes exactly so so we're so yeah I went
to the police when I got in but I was an
incredibly naive but I didn't realize at
the time I was naive until I got into
the police and I was crap at it I really
I was genuinely rubbish I didn't deal
with the confrontation very well I
didn't get them were my colleagues very
well I was more of a sort of nerdy nice
to play Dungeons and Dragons and I was
listen to listen to a placid house or or
progressive rock and they all just want
to talk about football so there's a real
culture clash and I know a jocks which
is those of us sort of type straight
jocks I mean there's a lot big mixture
people in the police but there's still a
huge percentage who I suppose you could
describe as Jackson or if they want to
talk about foot but I what one person
said to me you don't talk about football
what do you talk about it was a non
discussion so sorry was it was it was a
real real weird culture shark that
trying to break up a fight outside of
porno it was just you know I'm just I
all the understand Dharma being swung
about you know just I was absolute
arable at it but I just about survived
my probation I was that was on reports a
bit and then I moved up to the north of
the county going up to Glossop and I did
better but then I was fortunate to get a
month's attachment to the drug squad
her drug squad at the time was where all
the all the money was they were that all
the detectives wants to get into the
drug squad they're the biggest cars that
the biggest overtime they were they were
flush why did you get into that then if
you were if you were considered not to
be very good policing well by that stage
had improved and I'd stopped has started
to become got to start to rest people
and in what way would you say you'd
improved they do you feel like the Khan
you sort of gradually learned how to be
a bit more confrontational and oh it
might not be in confrontations dealing
with comfortable assorted sort of
reducing it and and I was just I was
fairly good at investigating crime and
catching people here do you think that
that nerdiness that you said in a and
they held me nerdiness definitely helped
and attention to detail and I had my eye
on CID
normally that's the kind of thing that
suited my personality well and I was
fortunate I think to have got to the got
the drug squads attachment with a bit of
a cliche it really was it sort of you
and your partner who is a kind of you
know hard-nosed job you you're picturing
me and Nubian detectives ordered it so
it was a bit more a us sort of the one
who is like a bit more concealer than he
was a bit more like and get out of here
yeah no there's something around on
there you know on the scene it wasn't
fine here and makes you find like a hair
or something you know was a bit more
like that a little bit if you if you
consider me me and the rest of them a
general partner because actually as a
police officer gently tend to work on
your own as a comfortable really yeah
most mostly so Yvonne said okay whenever
I think of a policeman I'd never think
of a lone policeman do you mean in the
while in Derbyshire
you know you there's not so many numbers
that you can go around in pairs most of
the time okay so yeah you know I was on
below most the time okay and just and
when you say catching criminals you
don't mean sort of hopping fences and
stuff you mean more sort of well yelling
good Marnell
no yeah the wealth or the forbid today I
mean the I remember um that just stood
outside the local nightclub in Glossop
and a guy came out had been chucked out
and he took took this rocks with it
through a window bearing in mind I'm
quite some distance away from it this
time I started moving toward him and I
actually said stop police brilliant and
of course they don't do they and I
thought I said it I can't believe it
just set that could have snuck up behind
em you know it's like plastic cliche and
you know a bit of a running after him
and you know this demonstrate in he's
like a I'm not a gun in it you know it
is like you stop and I run run after him
and ended up scrapping with him for five
minutes and brought him in and and the
fact that I was quite squirrely and I
managed
to discuss both those are the kind of
things that created reputation which
managed managed to sneak a attachment of
the drug squad for a month for a month
yeah which is not a long time and the
drug squad hated it
they hated having rookies again is
another cliche though I know I know but
they do those two go totally cliche but
I hated it because I just got under
thought we do know what we're doing if
they hadn't chosen to have it was
foisted upon them for management and
they thought it was dreadful but one of
them said to me who run a job down in
Derby one of them said I'm having to go
out buying some crack you got yeah it's
right okay so 20 quid the door Dalma
this this gangster called Danny Anderson
knock on the door us for Danny see if
you can come away with it crack cocaine
so in full uniform you walk down there
right by this daring but with drugs what
you had to be here to be sneaking around
so I'm thinking to myself build wise
that's like scrawny sort of like think
like physique that you've got you're
going to be much much more believable
than some of those other guys that money
that might have been the view that my
colleague told yeah I mean actually that
stereotype because once you start moving
amongst problematic drug users you
realize they come in all shapes and
sizes
yeah that's just part of the sort of
ignorance Terry time really well I mean
probably is probably what thought he
thought I looking at me Scotty
it'll be a minute simple as I do though
so you're walking on the street yeah and
you just sort of gone Yarra I'll give it
a go
yeah now I am crikey okay I had takes up
all of the right slang and I need the
commodity to a degree so I felt
comfortable I could buy it you know when
you say you need a commodity what you
mean yes oh I knew as much as I could
about it from an outsider's point of
view so you knew what to ask for sort of
how to ask for those sort of things yeah
yeah because it is a bit of a weird
thing you know you don't really know it
one please you know when I got old Paul
Hanif I'd come down here and sure so he
used to put the drugs in him and that
was an eye-opener because if you've
never
Jeron heroin before europe yelling what
the hell is all this you know I mean so
you die hard had done your research
obviously yeah so because I mean I was
good I was doing this attachment II need
to impress him you know what I was
talking about anyway so I went up to the
door and he interrogated me a bit why
are you from you know how long you been
doing this that kind of thing and asked
him for stone and he gave me this little
stone of crack wrapped in Whistler and I
came away like well got it
and you get a stone and you go and go
you can love to no one that sort of
defined the next fourteen years of my
life because the thing is you probably
see this on American civilian ear about
it this kind of work having done in
America for a long time yeah at that
point in 93 this was really new in the
UK I mean there was undercover work but
that was more sort of high-end books
wearing suits that kind of thing this
low-level in Coburg it just hadn't
wasn't happening at all in the UK and
the reason it's there was pressure to do
it is because in the newspapers at the
time there was the major moral panic
about crack and this dist evil drug has
come in from America and I remember
seeing Nancy Reagan on TV saying one
smoked of crack cocaine you're addicted
for life which is bollocks but at the
time I believed it and she knew oh yeah
yeah she knew yeah it's because the
Ronald Reagan didn't know much either a
reversal you let her talk for you yeah
it's much more friendly face and so what
happened after you taken that crack rock
did you you took it away did you then
just go back south and resting well what
happened no well then it started a
longer operation and so the squad
decided to try and sort of do a more
intricate job and catch his runners were
and and did you prove yourself without
then I did yeah I you know I'd one thing
I found quite quickly is that I can stay
calm
in the pressure so if I get an
adrenaline situation I feel like I've
got all the time in the world to think
about it which is which is as I
understand it is it reasonable
advantages probably why I took two it's
a quick read quality delivery release
model you
oh yeah why do you think you were so
lack natives because you know people
would think the opposite of a lighter
and nerdy guy goes into police forces of
well I mean I am
i Justi just have to approach it
rationally and just just try and slow
your thinking down and think things
through rationally but it just so
happens that my response to adrenaline
because don't don't get me wrong right
you know I was in full fight-or-flight
yeah I know is it risk and the
adrenaline was flowing but that just
make it just it just helps me relax well
that's the way I sort of see it yeah
I've been in situations which some
people would say are life or death
before and once you realize if I a
topless it with a rational mind set up
got ten times per chance again know the
situation alive absolutely if I panic if
you panic you're much more likely to
[__] make an absolute tits of it and
that it's on that sort of decision in
your head once you made that you tend to
approach things a lot more calmer than
everyone else I think that Pranay LAN
there had to be on another thing that's
exactly it it's just approaching it with
that rationale another thing that's a
but we like to use about is our PD or
more like eating yeah before about like
one a motion like they're fighting for
example on when they do the ring walk if
I say someone who's really worked up in
I was like put me money on the other guy
straight and it doesn't always work that
way but I think a lot of the time you'll
see the calmer people of just about to
cite decision-makers every time I think
that's a universal traceability
deducting big common thinking he's right
by three and so you begin you it took
that month and then you will you they
just kept you on for longer there just
got me on yeah and then I spend probably
more time doing that kind of work like
stock trading off than anything else
how and so how do you set yourself up in
that world because actually it must be
quite weird that you you can't stay in
the same place for quite a long time
then because once you made your arrest
people then know well he was easier than
one has not been arrested you know him
well I mean the jobs developed very very
quickly
an important point to notice that even
though he questioned me it wasn't really
that difficult no no really I'm not till
this gazes Doris
never met me before being told me a
record crop yes Crocker rock rocking
rocking track of rock rock rock rock
yeah yeah
the biggest drug dealer you know in the
world so he's he's going to want to get
rid of this stuff so that going at that
level is going to make it easier to
infiltrate the misery well yeah but they
won't know where's the tact their whole
drug scene was completely unawares at
this new tactic he went to prison and
you know people talk in prison yeah and
people talk with people all regionally
so it didn't take very long before I
feel neither there's tactics around
hmm so it instantly became more
difficult so short jabs to turn into
several weeks and then it wasn't long
before you wouldn't do a job less than
six months Wow
so I started moving around the country
and I'd go safe we dropped into luster
for six months and the team of cops who
were running the job and we're providing
the backup and the tactical equipment
and all these kind of things because it
active to help very quickly tactically
and they wouldn't know they wouldn't be
allowed to know my name where I was from
and they weren't allowed to ask me where
I was from or anything so my stay would
know my pseudonym has been as much as
the gangsters would know my pseudonym
and then very quickly that structure
came in place right and so what was you
seeing me I was different on each time I
used a cookie was one one okay so cookie
I feel like cookies down there yeah he
sounds really friendly and unthreatening
know I know I know a lot of who goes
well until my shrink huh why his last
name's cook but okay right yeah well you
know I mean oh yeah you know I was
calling myself Paul cuckoo Albert cookie
I just thought cookie yeah it's got a
good ring the way though it's believable
it's a believable street nickname yeah
because I've never you know yeah if
you've gone in there in your name of
Scarface you know would have been a bit
different
and then yeah then you got a bit to live
up to him yeah so we've gone from the
beginnings of undercover police work in
this country which he was on this time
around for - all right it's now a major
operation and you're know when we may
learn to the scene before in the movies
where you see the guy who's he almost
has to create a whole new life for
themselves when actors sort of get
inside a character they they take on all
of the sort of personal traits of this
character that's created in the head not
II know you're living a whole different
life than what you have being living did
you ever feel like when you were doing
these big operations that you are like
lose and kneel and become in cookie well
I mean when we eventually had training
is where the first years at in tough
training and up and I helped build the
training but we had some of the level
one undercover people the people who do
the proper spy stuff and come and help
becoming teachers and they always said
that we're not actors
we're playing just a different version
of ourselves so it is an interesting
question but I didn't really I never
found I was losing sense of self but I
did change quite drastically because it
essentially you have to manipulate
people and you have to minute manipulate
people within a community so you know I
would I would pick the easy easiest
people to manipulate which is often the
most problematic drug users look the
weakest the weakness but and the way the
way to to make use of those people's to
befriend them and empathize with them so
it's like weaponizing empathy so almost
sociopathic in a in a sense use in an
organized kind of way yeah absolutely
because you are you are manipulated
someone in the most stark and cynical
way really it's for the greater good in
what you usually great eternally great I
mean all of the time I was as far as I
was concerned I mean I knew I was
putting people at risk because obviously
they'd be at risk is the person
introducing me I knew I was making their
lives harder because they get wrapped up
in it they may get a prison sentence
themselves I knew I was discover I was
causing to these people quite early on
but I was taking the view
at the end justify the means yeah
because it's the end result of catching
the really vicious gangsters who were
murdering people is it all worthwhile
well I was I was bouncing I was an
ethical decision and at the time at the
time I was I was thinking that the
unjust remains oh I mean this is a sort
of lafiel question but you know you're
bringing them luck were you quite an
empathetic person or were you so quite a
hard young man when you were growing up
we were you taught to be because I'm
thinking to myself I've always sort of
being taught from being young like of
someone's on the street and they're like
wholeness or they're clearly heavily
drug user you should sort of take pity
on them
what were you sort of taught about those
people before you ended up sort of
trying to lock them up I mean I had a
very quiet I was quite politically
minded and I used to debate politics
with my parents and they would they
would you know quite a thickly minded
but I don't really think actually I
developed my sunset empathy very much
until my early twenties if I'm honest
though as a young person you can be very
interested in the arguments but that's
not necessarily feeling of the someone
else's point of view true yeah which is
why for most people get swept away with
that sort of thing in their in some
other as a 20 year old man remember I
was very hot a little harder than I am
now like my emotional side if I say like
the scenes we've seen on the TV you know
when are like I said you want to first
see in the Twin Towers 9/11 I was like
all that's really sad but it didn't
really here's but now when I say things
going on it actually hits us because
I've become aware of what suffering and
pain really as two people so do you feel
like by dealing with these people
emotionally you've switched on more
absolutely and I completely agree with
you I would trace a similar journey as
well I've become more empathetic but
certainly I mean I I learned in through
this work really and an adult develop my
empathy in that way so yeah emotionally
things touch me much more I think I've
got more emotional intelligence I think
that's probably the phrase that
you sort of make sense and you get all
the IDI learn more yeah more I mean
another thing is well this isn't true
across the board but I do believe it
like generally I think the older you get
the weaker you get emotionally as well
and I don't mean that in a negative way
I mean the more the more vulnerable you
become a little bit because when you're
20 you can be a bit more emotion the
ignorant be like I've got the rest of my
life
it's all going to work out good for me
generally but once you realize no
actually like it isn't how we all
expected life to work out you I don't
know I've seen people become who I
thought were really hard melt as they've
gotten all dust like it's been crumble
who I never thought would my own that
though is I do think that's very much a
cultural thing maybe that's also a stage
that some people go through those I
don't think that I've seen not every man
in my life and every woman in my life is
sort of gone through that same arc and
in other culture you'd argue it feel not
the opposite but I think maybe in
Western culture people are encouraging
more to hold on to things and so you
become a bit more like your immense size
things to some extent and as you begin
to empathize with other people a bit
more things become complete so it's not
a general rule but I'm just assuming
I've observed where I've seen people get
a bit more in touch with them evening
the regretful side of things i think
when once people realize they can't just
continue megohms fix and everything's
going to and harming other people as
what harm you told yeah and that's quite
a big change was to me one of the
biggest changes where you saying you
went through that during your time in
the police I was like I went through
heard that through undercover work I
mean I'll give an example what a guy I
manipulated in in Nottingham a guy
called coming and he he was a
problematic heroin user that he was a
drug dealer but he was on bail for drug
dealing so he was a perfect sort of
person with me to go because he was
connected to thee and to the group that
I wants to get into which was the best
for cartel run by Colin gung
he was connected to him he was that's
Aquarius supply was coming from and he
was introducing me so I manipulated him
I bought him presents I bought him and
one day I gave him a baseball Cup I said
I was have leftover from what I've been
shoplifting and he immediately took his
cap off put this new one on and look
looking at himself in the shop
reflection the shop doorways ah man
that's amazing needed a new cup I know
one day I found him leaning against the
same shop doorway and he was crying
it's his County man wha what's ugly he
said sir I'm a best mate from school
he's just died
died in a football pitch heart attack or
something so they even had to be the
healthy one you know surely it should
have been made it about that mean and he
said so mate are you gonna go to the
funeral and he looked at me like I was
an alien mmm don't be [__] stupid
last thing that family wants is some
dirty schmuck out turning up at her
son's funeral which really hit me
because you know how it's worth
remembering that however much society
and individuals look down on problematic
drug users it's very often as much as
they look down on themselves mmm so that
that was just one of the things that we
have really got me this is this is the
kind of person I'm manipulating and
making life more harsh anyway when he
was arrested at the end of the job few
months later he in the police Sally was
on suicide watch
and it's not because he was going to
jail which he was it's not because he
was rockland from the heroin when she
was it's because and he said this in the
police interview he thought I was his
one friend in the world
hmm [__] helmet so that is really a
lot that got really that really grip she
got really really does nobody ever wants
to make anyone feel like that ever even
if it's called the greater good and you
know you convinced her all the way you
don't code that would put like I think
if you didn't touch anyone would have to
be heartlessly honest you haven't so to
play that but I mean no I invited if you
so much you play the [__] oh I
wouldn't they fight like that yeah sort
of you someone said that the unit that's
what in
my lord I absolutely will be cut at the
same time I also think some people are
emotionally manipulative people you know
when they find when someone's angry with
you they'll say hustle you hoodlums and
then you open they're trying to get
better and harm you back because they
feel like you've done harm to them
do you know I mean yeah you have
anything to admit experience nobody in
the situation I think that's that that
was genuine truth yeah because I because
I know his situation then I know he was
he was struggling to connect to people
and those manipulative people that
you're referencing as well or people who
are naturally like that
who and I've met people who it's almost
like a way of life for them they don't
know let's say brazen like some people
and my guilt yeah there's nothing behind
the eyes this is how they survive that
there I think was a reptilian brain or
something Dan Hardy said like you're
just heartlessness like once that but I
like that all the time but for you
you're not like that you're doing this
as a job yes you're living with the
consequences of it so normal person goes
to a nine-to-five job that made them
it's like Shels all day the goal Vaughn
may have a bit of a bad back but they're
going to switch off and that's it you
have like permanent guilt clearly from
see to it like that did not just affect
you throughout the rest of the evening
are for weeks on end
Aloka for long Tommy and I decide I was
going to stop working undercover from
from the end of that child I mean it has
been all there was all sorts of things
happen in that job anyway just to give
you an impression of what led to me
thinking our car con didn't all is that
he introduced me to a left-handed it was
a real a person I really needed to get
get in touch with us really completely
within the within the cartel and got the
introduction any mattered with him and
it turned up in this car with his
twelve-year-old son in this by the side
of in the car like a little mini maze as
both had the shaved head flat anyway
open the dollar and immediately stuck a
knife into my bollocks and I could feel
the steel actually pressed in the game
against where you really don't want to
feel another [__] I forgot it the guy
not the MPAA it took another target
release
they also use some was there watching
yeah anyway you interrogated me for
about 15 minutes with the knife against
you and then okay yeah you only was a
who they don't know and they've come me
along we don't a me all these kind of
conversation is asking me again to Matt
ripped me up asking me in different ways
I knew eventually eventually thought I'm
gonna leave them not see or I'm going to
I'm going to get some some heroin and
you eventually sold to me and that got
me into that group that was about four
enough once into the group into the
operation the next day my backup team to
my backup tiragon sick so I have knee to
knee people on the team I met them in
the morning and one of them shall key
songs yes singing okay no problem the
next one shook his and and instantly the
hairs went up in the back of my neck so
this is this is just not right at all
now when you've been working day after
day working on the copper your
perceptions are quite finely tuned or
maybe just paranoid you're on the edge
you're on the edge you're on you really
focused and so I said to the guy running
the Java system up but I cannot have
this guy in the briefing car I can't
explain in detail it's just something
about his body language it's just not
right and bless him II suggest no
problem at all will exclude him both the
last questions and not blindly no where
you going anyway that job came to end
eventually that led on to Nottingham
sure police bringing down the best food
cartel Colin guns in prison at the
moment the well among gun was brought
down it turned out that the detective
that I take an exception to was an
employee of calling gun he'd been
employed to join the place seven years
before he would pay two thousand pounds
a month on top of his police wages plus
bonuses for good information and so SSA
been in something year there was the
[__] mutt Amanda Capri or [__]
movies called a bazillion like
absolutely your intuition was dead-on
and you probably saved my life
a lot of holy yeah but you shook his
hands yeah Chucky Spanish guitar that
movie come the depart placer sorry I
just saw her needed an audience under
pressure those reported are x-ray for
them yeah but all the way through that
job Colin good had been telling everyone
get any out on the streets that if he
caught an undercover cop then they'd be
tortured today for camellia so there was
all that that could have pressure going
on all the time so yeah in it you know
worry about me suppose the thing is once
they've seen your face I know who you
are or they sort of know roughly who you
are without always a worry for you that
something you're always worried about
like were you worried that in the same
way that criminals are worried that
there can be a not by the police or sort
of their doors kicked in were you
worried that you might have the same
wherever you stayed at night that
criminals would kind of come to you and
do whatever as each job went on and I
went from one city to another I you know
it was always in the background and you
are you start to look over your shoulder
that a little bit proper yeah oh yeah I
mean that Colin Colin gun guy who hired
go into the police force oh did he get
rumbled and well it was it was because
the job into a Colin gun was so good and
a little bit of luck as well it's a very
good piece of police work by nothing too
much a police and and he was and he was
caught but he was implicated in
providing the information which ended up
in some murders the judge sent him to
prison if guy his name's Charlie
Fletcher it this is all a matter of
record he dissented sent him to seven
years one year for every year he'd been
inside but in the debrief of that when I
met some senior Coburg police afterwards
I'm saying you know what what's going on
and the attitude completely to me and
turn from this scenic over places we own
about of course this happens with this
much money involved how can this not
happen what so when you think about it
logically
they've got millions upon gr worse to
play for what is it to pay this slide
again join the police force and like
obviously police force rages on no in
the other kind of money that is going to
be able
get paid be brave to miss me living on
bikes I see a double bubble net Hill
meaning all the time you know I'm in
yeah by 7 billion pounds a year because
it's like a venturi ring Ross who were
liras oh he's a rapper he got found out
to be a prison god and he was sort of
hidden all that behind but they said
that the reason why he was a prison
guard because he was paid to become one
so he could there's that guys I mean I
mean there's been V normally okay trust
because he his name is taken from
someone an actual drug dealer as well so
there's a lot of fakeness abode but
anyway it's chicken shop to break okay I
mean one thing that did strike me was
maybe to get the transferring out that
this what was the guy's name that you
you would be the zeros only friend
coming yeah um I guess that's part of
the issue as well as the portrayal of
these people is that they're either
their terrible drug dealers or users and
then you're the good police people and
it's much blurrier than that isn't it oh
it's far far blurry absolutely I mean as
I say at the end of that job it was just
because I've been doing it for so many
years at that point and I knew very
early on that the war on drugs couldn't
be won but I kept doing it to catch the
bad guy at the end but at that point I
think all sort of balance that you know
the unjustified amines I heard that from
kami and various other people are only
related I just thought I can't do this
anymore but very quickly after only a
few weeks I was tempted back into it I
got a phone call and it was the guy who
run that he run the operations at East
middle and special operations unit I
said would see we need you to do this
job because these are the hardest to get
into and these gangsters are even
nastier than the last ones these ones
the using rapist punishment Wow they
they are they are confusing complete
blanket terror and we've gotta catch
these guys so would see we need you to
do it and what I think that would tempt
you back into a situation where rape was
the punishments or anything
well what allow you come back to that
you know neatly you're out of it you're
sort of but you know I'm done well look
because
bad guys need patching and this their
that vicious we've got to do some human
really got a sense of you want to do
good in the world always yeah yeah
you're willing to put your own life at
risk in order to long-term save on us I
mean you're not you're not directly
pushing someone out the way of a moving
car saving them that way but ultimately
you saving a lot of lives at the end of
is the way you're saying yeah I mean if
there's no glory in it and so that's
what I we were you not to tell anyone
yeah yeah like your family not only
couldn't say yeah look cookies to my
rotten egg you know very well how did it
feel that when you find it like so the
not an encounter example you wear for
months and months and months on and you
find you get your man sometimes in life
I find that when you have to brush the
arse off or something and you finally
get what you've been waiting for all the
gruff sort of takes a shine off of it at
the end did did you ever feel like a bit
of an anti-climax oh god yeah and also
you get a journaling fatigue as well so
yeah for a couple weeks afterwards
though you just like getting up in the
morning and you just can't you don't
ever feel awake for so long afterwards
and that got longer after every job as
well mmm
so yeah that means exhaust was it but I
don't know if you saw Russian oil is
available did you ever have like never
feeling really down after happened and I
guess yeah especially you know things
like coming in there are berries are the
things I mean much much later on
eventually I mean I had lots of
near-death experiences you know it
blades threatened to me I mean the work
of our boys tripped me at gunpoint you
know all of these various various things
how was it the result that was what was
Northampton so when they phoned me up
and said these guys are raping people's
punished but all this was
how far into your career was this then
this is quite later not the last Java
did but very nearly something they
taught me 2004 so how many years five
you'd be an end of this point I'd been
all I've been doing it about twelve
years something like eleven atop that
I've been in the police say fifteen
sixteen years something like that burger
bar boys so so so nice yeah long ago I
mean did that quite I'm in a quandary
Stefan Birmingham but no basically the
moving into North answers are taking
over the heroin and crack cocaine supply
there how would someone do that not I'm
looking it in video how would someone
move into another area and take over a
scene and you just go in and kill the
other people as you go in and threaten
mental objects that what happens well
this is part of what I observed and part
of what for my later conclusions right
and because eventually I realized each
year that these are things things work
and the very last job I did I realized
that there's no end to this because
there that the drug war it is an arms
race with no chance of de-escalation
there's no peace treaties so everything
gets nasty so all the time I was
developing more tactics and police get
better and better investigating drugs
crime and there's always a push bucking
tactics don't you seen the wire is
accurate in the fact that there's always
a push but there's always accountable
use and the most effective
countermeasure that gangsters have is
the increased use of fear and violence
because the most successful gangster who
is the one who can most successfully
intimidate a community so that becomes
an arm straight to the place but also
between the different organized crime
groups of us or the street urban street
gangs a deal the most successful ones
are the scariest ones so Birmingham
gangs that obviously develops the
scariness over time much more
effectively and they need into
Northampton and did you can compete with
them that the judges couldn't be the
other but a big going there big backing
behind them you know
they're growing monopoly and they just
intimidated everyone and they raped
people yeah I mean I saw the police in
tell the Star to the job that they were
regularly making people than you were
using that as part of their intimidation
so they were raping they're raping men
and women that was the intelligence both
but but there was one particular Intel
that you know someone compared took that
they were going to rape your sister
right and they dead that was the
intelligence now II I went out actually
on a job in it is as after I'd managed
to get into them and I off that one day
that was Intel in the morning that they
they done raped someone in this in the
car that I've been gained into each day
so the cetera we're going to have some
contingency plans the woman the female
is being raped is not likely to report
it but if they do we need to be ready
with the evidence so if you get in that
car then you're potentially going to be
part of the crime scene so when you come
out with another seized your clothes and
sort it was all I can range in new
clothes wait wait the majors backup but
because when I put the call in to buy
some some brown and white off him in the
morning they turned up it's a different
car and the car that the done the ray
Peters was burnt out here to the edge of
the city so so you know they cover the
tracks figure out they knew what they
were doing as well I'll go outside here
they really knew what they were doing I
they were they were they they were
vicious they were genuinely genuinely
precious people and we're they they were
just normal guys from Birmingham normal
gangsters I mean there was such a
generation gangsters they grown up in
that from you know that their period
their father figures they are gangsters
as funny ELISA Dakin was in the car with
his dad
division of lock stock you know are the
doors are arguing with his son and that
looks like it's not uncommon as a
exactly I mean it the longer this goes
on the more that's going to influence
the young and and you know is arms race
means that the successful people the met
Ireland I mean I saw I met this kid in
just one example of money and in lust
few years years before and he'd just
been selling cannabis at other mountain
by that load the teenagers do a bit of a
cheeky kid actually quite likeable but
he got recruited into the the heroin and
crack see where you really have to be
violent or prepared to be violent to
survive because otherwise someone thinks
you're soft touching my grass job so
you're only safe she's safe or if you're
more violent so I saw him go from a
cheeky sort of pretty likable
seventeen-year-old to an absolutely
terrifying eighteen year old who was
instantly because he was learning how to
behave so the drug trade the ilis a drug
trade is shaping the personality of so
many of our young men in inner cities
which is changing the shape of
communities it's taken people whom if
there was opportunities more jobs
available and things like that who maybe
they'd be answering the phone filling
being polite there everyone or whatever
that it was worth our while to do that
the now picking up a knife basically
requires also people who are and people
who could be entrepreneurs or people it
could be you know start their own
businesses absolutely no reason what
we're saying is then they're not bad
eggs
obviously there are all bad eggs out
there but we're saying there are people
who are potentially middle-of-the-road
guys who could go on where the other
half and warehouse or but because it
opportunity-wise it makes more business
sense to them and they 18 their old mine
to be a gangster they're gone that way
it's not that I was watching Wiggly I
was watching the American gangster Liana
made a movie with Denzel Washington
which is a great place for such a great
portrayal of a gangster because there's
so many different sides to it and in
that film there's a great scene where TI
are common bodies character is being
baseball kid who want original to be a
baseball player but he says I don't
wanna be a baseball player anymore I
want to be like you and he's really
angry with them because he like mentally
a baseball yeah
you've got his life and you do imagine
that must be quite alluring for a lot of
people who see their older brother or
whatever
getting a really expensive car I'm being
like great well you know I'm going to go
and sell their drugs or you know I've
got a BMW why wouldn't you want my yeah
yeah yeah absolutely well I mean it's a
great misunderstanding about crime that
it's caused by criminals just not it's
caused by opportunity so if that 17 year
old I was talking about pink there was
no way the age of 17 he ever would have
been my violent without going into that
world but that was simply the biggest
opportunity for him and the drugs market
is a massive opportunity because there's
actually a very low risk of being caught
very very low risk why so long just
because it's coming out the Marquise
must be those thoughts we really hate
that it's so huge
and I think maybe our prisons may be
half full of people can X be the drug
trade it might be the thing that's
filling the prison's up but I still drop
in the ocean I merely laughing obviously
everyone knows someone who can get them
drugs and that's a lot of coincidence I
didn't mean but to me I mean I remember
being a young lad and I remember my
gloves on you well I was made to get
arrested and things that an armour but
thinking um you sound like I understood
the way they look with it because a lot
of them it wasn't the other way hit
people are made up on the news of our
people are just bad eggs and things I
know it's like if my choice is sucking
shelves at Tesco or the Corps or dealing
drugs for a lot more money a lot of them
and I'm not seeing that this is the
right decision but I understand the
logic behind are going to think I'll
take the [__] risk I rather be able
to pay rent and nicer place and other
nicer car and in it is a little bit
glamorous on the head as well you know
and this may be a point of looking empty
later as well but it it's really also
that some people can morally justify
doing the drug side things because
actually they think well I think the
government's wrong on this drugs should
be legal I should be able to trade
whatever I want I you know I should be
able to sell my friends an exploration
also also does wonders for your Achilles
as well because if you're I don't know
if you've got a son to provide for baby
to provide for whatever you're spending
yourself you know I'd rather give them
the best elation if that means I've got
to do this but I'm not doing every
tricky along so this with some of them
are just trying to make as much as the
come for them selves for people people
don't really think into the reasons that
go into it
people said but one thing that strikes
me about your story it does seem
incredibly lonely and like you're on
your own quite a lot within not only it
professionally because those people
can't call you by your real name you
know you know if you if you're working
with rape gangs the last thing you want
to do is be going out with a girl that
and they can then use his leverage or
whatever [__] hall you know it does
seem like quite a lovely job yeah it was
I mean thankfully I'm quite into the but
just thankfully thankfully yes a little
bit others I love you so think I'd wait
thing is actually prevalent on extra is
with whatever was encouraged to be and
now I think there's lot more diversity
in what people way that people see it
because actually they see the dude Bunga
ceases being an instrument as well yeah
I mean he was lonely sometimes and I
mean I was actually add in tough that
the happiest home life to be honest and
sometimes I was actually quite happy to
go to work and buy drugs off drug
dealers but so yeah it was a few years I
suppose it was a bit lonely but I have
to say though I did that so much of the
work I did still enjoy you know there
was that was that trauma to it but I did
I enjoyed the art of deceiving people
after I have to admit it you know it was
a was that was a thrilling it was
thrilling it was a feeling of developing
skills all the time developing all the
time learning you know you'd learn from
people every day another guy holiday
filled it to get you by Colin RT the
challenge ended always a new problem to
get around and that's the other that's
really in a weird way
I kind of like what you do when you talk
about dealing with some of the serious
criminals it's almost like being a
[__] lying to him I like some of
these people like they get a buzz off of
I mean and we watch the film lately
about a guy with bears on the second
channel and danger does bring a bit of a
buzz for people and obviously that got
you at some point yeah he did yeah I
mean even when that when I got
introduced to the burglar voice which is
fairly fairly terrifying but I have to
manipulate someone because they were
they knew the score they knew the
tactics how to manipulate someone in
Northampton - I spent weeks and weeks
living this couple giving them presents
like the shoplifting prison so I need to
look at yeah I used to love shoplifting
by the way grateful as well it's really
funny a lot of our guests really been
compelled by shoplifting in their life
like it's a mysterious rely assumed that
you were provided with the gear and then
handed it all as if I shot list of
listen or you actually shot mr. distance
I mean sometimes I was provided with
again yeah but sometimes you just have
to do it for your cover but it is quite
fun and now the police means we've sorta
got away with it
well yeah because I knew I was giving us
to feel rather someone of the team will
get resistance months later you know
enough to actually explain as sorry I am
TG shells for them but I get and so
you're giving them presents what kind of
things do you shop listing for and you
shoplifting in fronts emerge that makes
it going come in here and you'll so like
normally I just saw off but I'm like the
child clothes that was giving them
because I had a real a market for baby
clothes there's always a good market for
shoplifted million vote as small as well
so you can pull them in the chocolate
yeah and it's expensive in here you keep
replacing them so people you know
parents you know not very well off
anyway
so I was I was moved in four weeks and
weeks before they got got me an
introduction now on the way to meet the
Burgos where they were they were holding
two holding court in this nuclear Club
in the center Northampton I love you in
the picture here I'm ray tonight and it
we would imagine this a sneaker Club
sort of dark like yeah yeah yeah
absolutely Delilah beg Lomo loads it yes
Moki later the sneaker tables and I do
approaching it I'm 80 was actually
walking with a walking stick who's got
bitter gummy leg he's walking he started
to sway say no
he was texting me the color story you
given me because basically said we know
we've known each other for years this is
where we met this is what we've done
together we almost got caught
shoplifting doing this we know this
person this person he was grilling me
with elation did given me I thought this
is so weird because because I got a real
Kotori and I need tea and he's making me
rehearse a color story girls done
running this cover story oh my god you
know Mom so anyway but god damn he's
terrified I'm going to slip up to go in
there and instantly we get directed into
the gents toilets in the same Club is
quite quite big and he's crapping
himself I know this hooded figure came
right like yeah he comes there sort of
figure and he goes into the cubicle he
stand in the toilet he looks over the
top Isis what's this anyway then these
four figures come in door bursts I could
and these sudden figures it's walking
around me in a circle if you're so often
one of them head BOTS me
hello gives me a big in the ribs or
kicks my uncle and I'm just loving to
sort of stay there and the case keeps
hurting all the time he's asking me
questions and asking him questions right
and then Jackie and I'm taking her with
me again and this goes on an arm and my
ear guess had buttered and that is now
the urea really hurts me and this is a
sense of imminent violence was a
blessing creditor is going to erupt I
thought I was there there was color
density turn on me and then he just goes
like that
and the full go and it is yeah alright
and what you want such a hard one on one
please
so got one one point for her heroine
point for us and a crack and then gave
him before he quit a mirror away but and
but most of the guys running my gang
those bellies with the yeah they speed
those of this for going the poor
ventilation makes one of the ones below
the rebels a guy and the toilets to the
toilet us that was the left turn
and the rest of the Mossad of his team
but you never and you never you never
really got to me I suppose you're never
really going to get to meet the very top
because you're creaming off the millions
that you look at hundreds of thousands
no no all the work all of the work I did
whisper down and dirty grimy stuff on
the streets to be honest
did that feel a little bit like you're
winning a battle but you were losing a
war well I don't know because sometimes
do you do with intelligence that would
get that we provide intelligence to the
higher up people right you know by the
end of it you realize that actually the
ones who can afford the proper
corruption the ones who can afford to
pay the top dollar hmm anything they
don't get caught I think they also
period mm he's the police at certain
levels possibly also you say well I'll
give you an example give you an example
of the extent of police corruption as a
result of drugs manager we've have a few
questions about law firm in Manchester
we're not finished on the cover work and
I was working as a conventional
detective as a taxi sergeant things only
March 2011 and I got a call that one of
the houses in a field which is in the P
districts have been raided in my yard a
beautiful place beautiful this house is
sort of million-and-a-half property and
how you feel very raided by grey
Manchester Police and I went there
because I was there do TDS a little bit
out you know in your phone ad get some
other locals to to help you out and the
firmest cannabis growth converse factory
and they've been the seller of this
property and I thought I found the
sergeant Lee we do sell to them as well
I think there's 12 cops there
so I incredible says why don't you phone
ahead and you know we're gonna be taking
this crime off here anyway so in our
past you are wild by the
cloak-and-dagger this is no it's our
brief we don't talk to anyone at all
we've been tasked with bringing down the
empire of our own Cosmin hmm there are
in Coughlin you can look him up as well
he is allegedly or as this police
officer told me at the time a gangster
and so for south and on Chester those
his reputation in Manchester
and he said that what we've been touched
today to bring his that down his empire
so we're doing warrants and doing
medicine because we're we can't but
we've been told not to talk to anyone
not a single the cop and we've been
handpicked by the kid Chief Constable of
Manchester there's only one Chief
Constable and a so he runs walk several
thousand cops him on Chester we've been
picked by the chief himself as people
who are most trustworthy and we're not
to tell any of our colleagues what we do
and we only report to the Chief
Constable so I said to him wow so you
are the untouchable son and he says yeah
but we've been told you're not allowed
to call ourselves out now it's hard to
convey just how extreme and the thing
that is this is a very straightforward
guy that we've been told yeah but we're
not supposed but I'm telling you right
now I've been told not tell you listen I
feel stupid but but but you think of it
it's hard to grasp the importance of
this to the actual impact of this yeah
the Chief Constable of Manchester can
only trust there are 12 in all of these
Constabulary yeah because there was an
anti-corruption thing because of just
how much and whenever how easy it is to
poke your boss it is I mean don't get me
wrong I've worked a lot with Greater
Manchester Police those are some
fantastic people that it doesn't take
many people to create a reputation of
being people are just people under 30
view resources on robots but it be
forever from Robocop he is actually half
robot again another film way you've took
his documentaries again so you said at
one point earlier on that you got in a
situation when you met these burger lads
but what they like strip the ultimate
are we going I used to sometimes wear a
wire but you'd make a very careful
decision whether you're going to wear
any technical equipment because you know
you are liable to get search time to get
searched a few tardies but I thought and
it was fortunate that I really fortunate
I didn't have to wear one on this
particular occasion because I just
turned on me and there was four of them
and they turned on me this day and I've
been dealing with him for weeks
and they took me to the edge of the
racecourse which is big park obviously
used to be erased cause in in
Northampton and they said right look to
the shirts are one of mine a god and
they're in the band or the trousers it
was a self-loading pistol handgun it's
light strip you wearing a wire man if
you are you're a dead man hmm so I strip
now keep going click I know me strip
naked including my socks and shoes and a
disturber and other saying ah look at a
little white boy girl and the
thoughtless [__] told you bastard
anything I say ahead at this point as
well is a sense of relief that you
weren't wearing a low you can have no
idea how much really what Armenians
Italian McNally yeah I was I was I was
changing the comfortably alright I don't
get it I wire down a mate and say a good
old boy and what were they when they
they affect on your white blue Wiley
what are they well the big about boys
happened to be black line okay
just waking and and so stop trying to
touch his legs it got really long legs
up let me free oh and then yeah yes
we've had a lot of complaints about the
table sorry about yeah
name a teacher in the other part it will
be a difficult in the middle of the
public every day life yeah just have to
lunchtime right kids were playing on the
drugs then you are left in the puppet
with no sight at all no no I put a bow
I'm pretty much pretty sharpish yeah and
thankfully they sold to me stillness I
think it sold me for four point four
actually right so you really have their
trust by LuPone then yeah that was
really well did they never come
obviously they trusted me more after
that
due to in fact after that and the next
time I saw them was interested because I
was a weirdly for that job I used the
name woody it's a pseudonym which I
think of as being ironic because
actually you know it's actually my name
but it worked but the next time I saw
them I got in the car noticed it was of
this really really big car big black car
got in the back and they didn't that
they were normally completely straighted
and didn't tend to use any drugs but
this day the open the doors big fog of
cannabis smoke came out and I got in
there and the mainlanders sat there and
he's like really stoned sighs he says
what do you man what do you man why they
call you woody man because you looked
like Woody Allen man to keep what do you
look like a kid that do really sure we
all look alike to you so anyway the way
the really story the wind is just you
know thinking on your feet Tucker thing
I said well no actually it's a nickname
that came from a few years ago as a am
you've seen the film Toy Story yeah and
he goes oh yeah yeah
together - toy story writing about
substance everyone's relaxing this 2008
DVD player in the back it says well it's
a bit in not when the character woody
yeah he's picked up by the naughty kid
and he gets and gets it like a
magnifying glass and burns old into that
yet to show you so at the time that Phil
came out I asked you had skin comes from
that well and I don't have laser surgeon
he was burned out can you see the scar
yeah anyone oh yeah and I said so my
main start calling me woody brilliant
anyone oh man not so tight so you know
we love each other points along Mei
she's ever heard anything in prison ever
since going to him it's kind of skin
cancer yeah but I just thought I just
thought I was quite weird that you know
this this guy he was all violence and
guns and rapes and things would think
there was really cruel thing to do yeah
it's amazing how people who really talk
evil people have this
idolan and i'd like to talk about TV and
movies for me when you say the word
gangster Tony Soprano was the first
thing I think of and he was someone who
had a very he had two different sites
women in The Sopranos where he was like
the family man who had a real source for
animals and anything got the animals and
they would send them off to depend like
you to get really upset about it but
then he think nothing of putting a
bullet in someone said once he went out
the door and was Tony Soprano like the
gangster which is sort of the funny
thing because I mean again American
gangster which I was watching the other
day they were talking about how you know
the Italians in America they have a way
of doing things and order and those sort
of things and the black guys who are the
gangsters were seen as the disorderly
guys and what you also realize is the
both of those obviously think that
fiction you know it's not true and it's
all based on they sort of helps the
police in a way to dehumanize both sides
of those people yeah
and you do sort of realize that that's
the basis of those things and actually
the reason you know Italian gangsters
portray themselves with some set of
morals is because it allows them to
perpetuate that myth and get further
arts I know
under the manipulator community
particularly because what happens the
longer the new police drugs the more you
separate police from community yes and
so the communities that are dominated by
organized crime they enjoy taking on the
community figure yeah so I mean is an
infamous gangster in Salford her mercy
sure mercy and he shot now he was just
part of an ongoing war in there still
going on in Greater Manchester but he
stood former mayor of Salford he didn't
come last he came forth but and they've
got a massive share of the vote because
he'd become such a public figure
everyone knew everyone knows in Salford
that he's a gangster everyone knows that
he's got a whole team of thugs who's
beating people up for drug deaths the
you know that shooting people carrying
weapons he everyone knows that's why I'm
still a community when you go further
back like for example the Godfather the
first one and that was obviously written
about like a strong from inspiration
from real people
the godfather was called alpha because
he was seen as like another God for the
figure of the community so like when the
police didn't handle like the first
thing and the Godfather is he's going to
the Godfather because the police haven't
given him justice and he wants him to
sort out the people who his daughter
something like that and a lot of them
still try and because if you win
people's hearts like you're saying the
people equally people who terrified of
you you've got a longer chance of
staying in power but also if people
think of you an N and B R and we're like
that if you'll know someone for some
really terrible yeah well no but you
last longer as well as know yeah Zelly
explain playing both Miriam isn't it
some people do see and you know not to
sort of get take it to better but some
people do see the government as just
sort of a legalized version of that in a
way you know some people don't you know
they see paying taxes a sort of a racket
and those sort of things which isn't
necessarily true and you know a lot of
the things that are done and this is the
mass of conversation that we're not
going to go into because what other
things us come up with yeah I think
there's a lot of good people who get
involved like yourselves who get
involved with the right idea and then
realize there's corruption in everywhere
they're everywhere there's people
there's money you in every way this
money this corrupt which is what makes
anything to come Hot Fuzz yeah yeah
which is actually what makes that film
so great is because that's actually it's
it's about no no I'm not going on The
Godfather the hospital has a really
great holiday another very funny but
it's also about how policing the sort of
old basis to the film is that this
straight-laced cop goes into a town and
wants to lay down the law but these guys
have got their own law and it's their
own racket and there are gangsters in a
row right and it sort of shows that
anyone can kind of fall into that it's
not just you know the size of people
would normally associate with them and
they all argue is for the greater good
in the same way as an Italian family
would or anyone in what sort of area so
you must have come in to contact them
with a lot of different cultures as well
and sort of how you feel with a lot of
those different things with every time
that you like wheeling do you have to
research that without something to learn
as you went along because it's not every
actions going to act the same Olli
no I mean well you can research to a
degree but on sort of street level
slung and colloquialisms and things are
so varied and they're so changeable you
just have to start to have an ear and
adapter very quickly to be understood
you can be you can be calling I mean
there was a there was a time for short
short time in Nottingham where where
crack was whiskey right he's of whiskey
because white white whiskey right and
brown was brandy you know all these kind
of slung things that's what you mean but
the slang of the language is really
really changeable you can get found out
if you don't know yeah absolutely yeah
you can stand out a great deal you have
to do that well what do you think makes
a good undercover police officer being
humble I'm pathetic if you can't have
any kind of aggression and you can't be
similarly relaxed to a situation with
aggression so you so the ability to be
non-confrontation mind you having having
said that sorry oh yeah so yeah unveiled
to think when you see those are those
are the essential qualities but you
can't be someone who has any kind of
confrontational bone in your body really
because when I when I have been
confrontational
it's been not an angry reaction it's
been a decision to do so in order to
protect myself if I'm excellent it's
very calculated what you're doing it's
not you're not lashing out your tuner
because you know it's in your best
interest in my situation if you just
under fear self for example but it seems
to me looking at you that the fact that
you don't come across as the most
physically important Guardian that you
are sort of very non-confrontational
naturally but it would benefit you a lot
in your line of work yeah I would say
that's not the case you haven't
confrontation was a good thing come back
to that guy he was the most obliging to
both sides
I just sort of mulling over him when he
found out and people work out he's
working both sides and there must be an
incredible feeling of betrayal in the
police fair as well and also I guess the
suspicion that he wasn't anyone who knew
that he was doing that if they're if
they're also an our suspicion between
everyone that works with staff did you
ever felt do you ever feel like you
couldn't really trust anyone that's even
within the police force because you find
out that guy's doing that surely that
undermines so much of what you're
working on what you believe in yeah
absolutely I mean when he was found out
it was incredibly unsettling from
familiar I genuinely thought it was very
few people I could actually trust
relevant and yeah it is it may just work
in life much much less comfortable and
you don't you can place the face without
really in also within the police forces
as a whole you must see you must they
must make you wonder who else within and
that because someone must have known
along the way yeah I mean you think so
but the thing is it
what's unsettling is that there's no way
he's the only world yeah you know but
that's that's the way the tactics and
corruption is going and that's only
going to get worse because the value in
the drugs market just keeps increasing
you know 7 billion pounds a year that
buys a lot of police officers it buys a
lot of prison guards and the only way we
can fight this corruption is by getting
rid of the illicit drugs math can make
regulating drugs the only way that's
what certainly went off watch a couple
interviews before today is hope you kind
of described it in a roll away as you
know I'm the embassy with a book it's
like it were really is just pissing into
the wind here we need to do this
differently the news of God totally
different actually to what you have when
you first came in over let's get the bad
guys to now release the bad guy well not
necessarily as a blogger but shouldn't I
think one interview you said we want our
police officers catching real criminals
and rather than the vulnerable people
who are self
the kid a lot of the time yeah precisely
oh because we've talked a lot about
catching gangsters yeah yeah okay I
caught Colin gone and bergerbar boys but
actually I put a lot more people in
prison they were vulnerable and just
needed help you know there's so many of
the problematic heroin users that I'm at
a large number of them were
self-medicating for childhood trauma
very often for childhood abuse either
sexual or physical I mean as the woman
are making Northampton and she she said
to me I can be Michael I can come off
heroin no problem and I've been
sometimes but only trouble is when I do
I become suicidal because then I start
remembering the childhood piece that I
got the sexual abuse of my uncle and
dannis car becoming suicidal so for her
it was a pragmatic decision but ghosts
going on to heroin she was keeping
arrived because heroin is a very
powerful painkiller of the body it's
also very powerful painkiller of the
mind and another thing I lost with Paul
homicide in a weird way was it seemed to
motivate him in terms of giving him
purpose so that every morning when he
got up his job and mission in life was
to find a way to steal enough crop to
get as much money in order to afford his
heroin and I think for some people who
are just solve empty and I'm not saying
Paul was but some people are they so
they need a purpose and in a weird way
they find that through drug the drug
yeah it means they don't have to stare
into the void they have it means they
don't have to face up to that lack of
connection that habit it's amazing how
much in life bad childhood experiences
echo throughout the rest of people's
lives as some people are 60 years old
and still not although up and when they
were 10 years old and yet what may be an
unusual is the way that we then treat
those people because you know I mean a
lot of the time that you hear I mean
especially in the UK I imagine a lot of
that is influenced by so we're talking
about the war on drugs action american
term which removes the UK you know
the crap American drug wishes come
overseas a lot of this seems to be
influenced by American culture in some
way and the way that American culture is
gone and arguably now because we share a
lot of our press barons there's been a
similar portrayal in the UK and Sky News
going in a similar way to where the Fox
News is going so it's sort of beginning
to portray people the poor or the
underprivileged or whatever you want to
call them as not people who I'm not a
fast are or have not had a fair chance a
crack of the width as people who haven't
tried hard enough and they've gone down
the route because it's the easy route to
go down and so it portrays the most of
the people who are perpetuating their
own absolutely yeah absolutely let's
let's make you clear the war on drugs is
a war on poor people yeah and it's a war
on minorities
I mean input to the racism in the war on
drugs is just incredible a black person
in the UK if I stood in the dark they're
going to be sentenced for drug offense
they are 13 times more likely to be sent
to prison than or my person now that's
just beyond unacceptable i'm spondylus
on the logic behind it like for me why
not help you over I don't know there
isn't that much logic to the war on
drugs really but a plea maybe imagine
these plea to given these powers in the
beginning of the 70s
said right we've been told in each cuts
drug thunders and now they give me
statistic that they need to capture
certain amount of drama but for the very
first time professional drug squads are
set up very very first time so they've
got right this is our job we've got to
catch drug dealers hang on what the drug
dealers look like right so that that
draws I'm prejudiced yeah you know if
you ask every one of those people they
say oh you racist dubby stupid no insult
me yeah but once you start thinking oh
god what does it drug dealer look like
then that amplifies racism the fair so
if you think what happened to the 70s
the stop search increasing and
increasing and then
you've got for example the Brixton riots
yeah which were Wilson basically I think
most historical commentators would say
was much very much down to the stuff and
service policy yes American place yeah
that's not an accident that it's ten
years after the Mideast drugs are hmm
that's the racism that is being fueled
in our societies by policing drugs could
have you experienced private and private
conversation racism within the police
very rarely
there was one South African X African
who was in the police who I was shocked
stunned to hear say that he trained his
head dog is a dog handler trained his
dog to black by black people which which
which astonish me Rosa de nieve nineteen
year old but tell you gentlemen of
African attire as well as law my god
have sinister star wife great from Kitty
PU but but three but no I didn't I
haven't come across I come across hardly
any and he any at all either racism but
that doesn't but he's endemic and he
will approve face to statistics the
proof that you know he can't argue with
our statistics that the racism is so one
of my mates who joined the police he
said yes the police officer just as he
was joining he said like what isn't
makes a good police officer and the
police are not like this law I've known
since I was three years old so it's like
he's not going to lie there was about
this you know I mean and he'd said he
said how it helps me this is this and
then at the end he went and you know
what else he said now what you went and
helps if you can beat up a black blood
listen I was like well we're gonna say
loud toys have something off you know I
mean but I'm going to say that but I
just remember being like [__] hell
they just shot Simmons
I suppose I'm no I'm actually naive
about it like racism because I've never
encountered it being a white lot like
from Newcastle
there's not not any like black Asian
people up there this is quite compared
to London it's so different so coming
down London's really open my eyes I mean
policy was racist is all in in beginning
of the 90s there are no more black drug
dealers come white chocolate
criminality across is racially equal it
is a proportionate the CH proportionate
is apportion earth is also partly down
to then the fact that if you if you
assume that I mean you know if you
assume that black people let's just do
black and white people now right if you
assume that black people are carrying
drugs and therefore you search more
black people the likelihood of you
finding drugs on those black drug
dealers is much higher or in actually
there's a load of white people with
holding drugs because it's not searching
them absolutely and there's a beginning
of the nineties the reason that I was
asked if I put wanted to go and buy that
crap of crack cocaine is because in the
media there was the moral panic and the
moral panic was about black people
dealing crack yeah quite clearly all the
tabloids that's what they were talking
about so the pressure from government to
police sources was catch those crack
dealing gangs so the energy was directed
towards black people so how do you think
that we solve this issue in reality what
would you do things differently the only
way we can stop the accelerating racism
from the drug war the only way that we
can remove the corruption that it's
causing with the police and prison
service the only way that we can save
more lives and reduce harm is to
regulate the drug supply
you've got to take the whole market away
from organized crime completely
so we how do you do that well you break
it down into individual policy chunks so
for example heroin is actually the
easiest one you prescribe heroin right
they do it in Switzerland when they
start to prescribe prescribing heroine
in Switzerland is really an accolade
they they reduce crime mustard Lee
Berger is reduced and they virtually
eliminated street prostitution as a
result we're in it because they've
rescued people have been sexually
exploited and do they have an NHS there
or is that part of the privacy seem like
they're giving or they selling giving
right that's clusters they're not paying
for that they're giving it to them that
and they're looking after people those
traumatized people who need help and so
they are reducing the number of people
using it very successfully no one has
ever overdosed in one of us
facilities no one in fact no one's died
in a drug consumption there anywhere in
the world and you know even if someone
had it's still less than if they were in
exact cried an acknowledged right so
that they looking after people and it's
it because you didn't regulate him you
can regulate this not like throws on
Paul was on the show he said he was God
he was the gonna needle in himself if T
times a day or something whereas if if
the government are fully in control and
supply and that they can keep him at X
amount I mean it's quite interesting
because a lot of people criticize that
system so you can't prescribe heroin to
Barry not even because they'll just did
this one more and more well actually
they let them have as much as they want
to send you one so when they go on to it
and almost every one of them also
upgrade a filmer beeps tomorrow
Halloween and more and more and they
keep increasing the tolerance over the
space of about six weeks and in
virtually every case after six weeks to
eight weeks because they've got space in
their life for other things and they've
got the therapy going on they start to
bring their own amount down and then
release and because of that they're not
shot list and they're not robbing people
and things so that and they're not
creating the nine local gangsters or the
gangsters from here because their trades
disappearing but on the other end of the
spectrum you've got cannabis and that
could be done quite easily as well I
think Canada are about to regulate the
cannabis market across the whole country
but the reason we urgently need to
regulate cannabis is because less than
one percent of teenagers can buy alcohol
you know you go into a pub you got this
big budgets as US 25 it's really
difficult nowadays
dealers don't ask for ID they only are
they only want to see a 10 pound low
over sixty percent of our teenagers in
this country have got easy access to
cannabis and that's not right the drug
can be harmful for teenagers we
shouldn't be laying them get it but
perhaps even more important than that is
the whole structure of organized crime
drug dealing organized crime recruits
through the teenage cannabis market
right that's where teenagers get laid on
and at await they get laid on half an
ounce
you know come back when you sold those
14 1 gram deals you know pay me that
they're involved in the market and then
they're corrupted into into the more and
more dangerous stuff that's where it
comes from so you can separate or you
can protect our teenagers from organized
crime and the drugs if you regulate them
I would start with cannabis so what do
you do because I think then then we get
into the details of that because it's
very clear what your idea is legalize
drugs and you can regulate it yeah and
that's the basis what do you do with um
now the sort of the chemical drugs the
drug like accessing things oh yeah well
a little bit about we look MDMA does a
good friend of mine and fantastic
campaign called Amory Coburn
she lost her 15 year old daughter to an
MDMA overdose now her daughter Martha
swallowed it several doses by mistake
because she didn't intend to die of 91
percent pure MDMA now if the MDMA market
had been regulated if you could buy to
the pharmacy and you show the you're
over 18 with a pretty photo ID she
wouldn't have enough to get hold of it
because I would have got rid of the
black market right what if she had got
hold of it even despite the regulation
she would have the education to know how
much to take you wish you learn how much
and each individual dose would have been
regulated that would've been warnings on
the packet exactly how much to take is
quite clearly defined Martha wouldn't
have died and virtually all of the MDMA
deaths wouldn't happen if it was
regulators then Mike my question to you
because it's you're sort of talking
about like a forget big news like an FDA
kind of model where it's like it's
approved by those people yeah good
that's a good vehicle is if I bring this
water is not just maybe wasn't American
magazine kind of do it how similar
regulation yes you have to you have to
be very careful what you put in food we
do it we're very very good at regulation
in this country and so um then when you
get into that then there are they're
still defend it most people say well the
horses bolted now it's gone
the holes halfway down the field and
we're saying let's go catch that horse
because new drugs are being come up with
you know people are trying to cook up a
new stuff all the time
there is
the old fan of legal highs for a while
which which caused a lot of issues
allegedly I don't know I mean I never
tried it no I don't know that many
people you did what do you do about
because also I mean Katamon
you know ketamine is a tranquilizer how
do you regulate all these things that
people want to get high on and how do
you do that well whatever the drug is is
safer if it's regulated right so if
someone's going to do it we should try
and keep them alive and reduce the harm
policy should be about saving lives but
you took all the other sub novel drugs
that come along all of the legalizes
they weren't MPS's they only exist
because of drug prohibition are a
product of after prohibition if cannabis
in red been regulated fifteen years ago
you wouldn't have had all the chemicals
like spice like exactly you just
wouldn't have you wouldn't had it it's
not too late because if you look at
tobacco as an example we now have the
lowest tobacco use rate in this country
since 1940 that's only possible because
that chemical is regulated you can pop
plain packaging education has played a
big pot unless he can't educate until
you regulate because otherwise what are
you educated about is also it to be fair
that took I mean I don't know how long
way since 1940 that's 80 years almost
right that's a few generations that I
think in time to cabbage I decided to
take an ear two years to get there
because the education on someone started
putting black lungs on pocketer tubs not
only started about 20 year ago so it's
not taking long to sort this over and
then a bit of entering purpose I'm not
saying I'm not putting arguing against
you what I'm saying is it's gone we've
seen how long it that was a few
generations of watching people die at
lung cancer watching people die from you
know the thin people didn't smoke but
grew up in a smoking family dying of
lung cancer or all you know whatever you
want to call it whatever you know
smoking causes and that's part of it now
is actually a lot of people are very
scared of these drugs and it were almost
being scared into regulating these
things in a way well yeah I mean the
thing is we've three years in a row with
our record progress increases
does for the first time this year are
higher than no deaths in the UK and this
is urgent
this is an epidemic this is a crisis and
we need to do something about it
since drugs were banned in 1971 they've
got stronger more varied and cheaper
when I started buying heroin in 1993 I
was paying ten I was paying ten quid 2.2
when I stopped with 14 years later I was
paying 10 quid 0.2 and that point II was
stronger than when I started
warming because we have no impact on the
drug supply policing doesn't bring that
price down it gets easier and easier for
gangsters to sell it and so they're in
competition also the Prada gets stronger
and stronger and stronger because it's
its own sub market it's not arguing I
mean well you know what price is at what
prices up I'd smelled milk in 1993
compared with 14 years later you know
it's completes the only inflation boost
the beating product is going down in
price getting cheaper yeah and now we've
got fentanyl career which is which is an
adulterant in heroin which is in
devastating North America and the last
few months but the last few weeks we've
had some Dustin in the UK for me
personally there's the elephant in the
room that the government are ignoring is
they just matter what laws you bring in
it doesn't matter what you do people
want to get high and that will never
ever stop because people have hard days
at work people have depression people
have experiences when they're young
people assume they just want to show up
and have a good time you will never ever
stop that so you will never ever want
you ever stop people taking drugs it's
impossible to stop once you grasp that
fact will actually get somewhere but
until that happens we're going to keep
pissing into the [__] wind that's
absolutely right I'm well sad to me a
people do you want to temporarily change
that software yeah then it's no
different no glass of wine having a
glass of wine after work like many four
year old housewife don't you know I mean
it's just a different version of that
and I is more acceptable and I think
unfortunately one of the main reasons
the main issues is cannabis because it
has so many uses and there's so many
companies are terrified of that getting
legalized because if I'm part of the
alcohol trade or the medication trade I
know that I'm going to take a massive
work if people can just grow [__]
plant and not get that money and then so
the argument about that would be who are
the people who have the biggest and I
mean the production who the people who
are very good at and called making that
sort of thing it's the people who argue
medicine the people already do alcohol
so you need to find a way a millionaire
mirrors are swinging those people
unfortunately law those people are not
from the countries they would serve if
this was made legal yeah exactly
so it's also make sure that the people I
don't know like they're all the white
collar's lot like the white-collar
criminals like in my opinion like
they're making a [__] you can argue
this racket but then we were getting
into really sort of nobody so what I'm
saying it's all but I wrongly just come
by the skin far away because it is going
to be people with brown skin who foot
been made with money off of that and
that's why they fight in it my opinion
it's got nothing to do with what's right
for the people
oh don't take kind of is good it's bad
for you it's all our money I think we're
all agreed and not making I'm not saying
anything you another suddenly I'm just
saying because it needs to be such an
unnecessary yes
and what is interesting from my side is
obviously there's regulation there's
other industries where things are
regulated and I'm not trying to give you
a hard time I just want to make sure
that people don't think that just allows
you to come on and be like legalize all
drugs and then let you go what what
about there are industries where things
are regulated Alcohol Tobacco those sort
of things some people still want to
avoid paying tax they want to do it
themselves they want to go direct to the
consumer what would stop someone from
still being a gangster being underground
and doing it their own way well I mean
the most important thing about
regulating drugs is to remove the black
market but you make a very good point
that there is still a black market for
for example alcohol there are certain
parts of the south coast where it is
estimated that some percent of alcohol
is sold is actually smuggled so there's
still Logano's car involvement my
godfather was killed for smuggling
cigarettes actually well another great
reason for breakfast I'm joking but
that's only avoiding tax on 10% of the
market right the drill is the illicit
drugs market is a hundred percent what
you know is injured so you're talking a
small very tiny percentage that's reduce
to the black market and that's a massive
improvement though that that money is
not enough money to buy yourself people
to join the police and we're also sort
of talking about I read a book a few
years when i was kid at opponent
Belton's books it was called high
society and it was about a minister who
tries to legalize drugs because one
minutes it's not about one minister be
allowed to suggest the law that can push
direction and so you talk about
legalizing all drugs mate very basically
the situation you're talking about it is
it is it right to call it something that
could happen I think it's inevitable I
think that the war on drugs is it is
beginning to die because there are
politicians there are many women at leap
UK we speak to lots of politicians and
lots of politicians advisers and there
is a great sympathy for the VAV I mean
our people want an evidence-based policy
but this has to start at the public
first the politicians have to be
confident that they can get voted in on
this topic so so actually it more
important than the politician system is
the public and if anyone listening or
watching this is pervaded and please
you've just become part of the social
movement unfortunately like I think that
there's still particularly people who
are all of the age of maybe 45 right now
Roskill may be brainwashed into what
people were told so many years ago but
like to play my grandad for example drug
users are scum to him general I mean
there's not there's no education there
for what it's all really about you know
domain right I think it's going to take
for like people who are like our age
when they are 50 60 years old when we're
so controlling the old people's or and
not education and had so much time to
marinate that we might actually just
take it's going to take an eraser yeah
it's gonna take 20 years probably just
ratings actually quite like some
cannabis but unfortunately you can't
have any climb it's not legal thing is
there are other countries now other
places where it is becoming Nikolas yeah
I I do kind of calendar the big one
that's the one that that's gonna have
the most impact on the whole country and
Canada and the reasoning the reason yeah
the reason that's going to have the
biggest impact is because Justin Trudeau
campaigned on it as a child protection
issue which it is right and as soon as
you start framing that to people that
this is about protecting our children
and once the evidence starts coming from
Canada and that's the big Domino is
going to stop and absolutely sell it to
the people not literally thought somehow
we saw the idea yeah we've got to
protect our children from drugs because
they can get to easy access to them in
the moment and we need to protect them
from the black market which is
corrupting them right can get rid of
that black market though because that
black market is you are also
angering it by poking me - I mean and
saying we were middle and be also and
they're not gonna go down without a
fight
yeah they're not only many drug dealers
out there to go cooler just put a [__]
on a moving feel I go yeah John slash
shows us yeah well I'll cannabis ironic
this is actually the biggest argument
I'll have with police officers the
police officers argument or regular many
police officers argument is that they're
not just going to go away they're going
to do more gangster [__] like what well
that's it like the like what exactly but
the thing is there's a real danger
without here you because that's the view
that these people are bad and they're
always going to do something funny or
not with your narration or thing but
that's prejudice you know people are not
born that they are they are it's not
criminals that cause chromis
opportunities but what I so what I'm
saying to you is as all swings on the
positive the north and that's I'm saying
so the my argument or the idea that I'm
putting forward I don't necessarily
agree with it is that these people
aren't bad but you are taking away huge
revenue streams to them and if someone's
built their whole life around you know
I've got to BMW I've got whatever so not
going to suddenly rather bone because
that's too big a risk no no but that's
one sense you say how do you how do you
n do with those people because my is
quite tricky isn't it back well it does
avoid a social issue in that the fact
that there are less opportunities for
poorer people is something that's a
wider political issue in general I'm
thinking about right now with mister
such a weird comparison but in the
YouTube community awhile ago there was a
revenue stream of fifa coins where
people were sort of semi illegally
making money out of selling digital
products on the internet and that was
taken away by a company and people were
literally making hundreds of thousands
of pounds apparently offered for making
million
yeah apparently some people millions
pounds or this sort of thing and well
done to them and you know who you are
holding they are together but anyway I'm
not I'm not better not leading trying
fingers when once thought was regulated
and that income was no longer there
people have to just make do and wait
what you said is well what are they
going to do and if those police officers
haven't got a response where they can
say well we'll just do this what are
they gonna do do it once you take away
that main supply of income it's not like
they can just create new
no no exactly it can't create another
drug because people have already got
that they've bit you've eliminated that
now what about I mean the arguable thing
you know that there is other stuff they
can do you know there's gambling and all
sorts of things that I can do but then
but you're arguably taking away an issue
which is a huge amount of yeah yeah yeah
but all opportunities for crime are
already being tightened yeah so you
won't create more crime by regulation
now enough not necessary market bum good
point
yeah which is it the problem is it does
all seem a little bit too easy doesn't
it or it seems a little bit too simple
so there going to be people out there
who have the opposite argument to use
only we need more regulation of those
are I'm pretty hard for several decades
yeah it's time to wake up and realize it
this isn't working obvious well the
cannabis it's not just futile it's worse
than that it causing great harm and it
has to be also that it's down to the
education and people and people vote in
the right way that they put pressure on
their MPs as well you know we have to
have people actually contacting their
own pees and saying this is an issue hmm
because it actually what I find
interesting if you had two music
festival something like that probably
arrests immediate miserable at least I
mean you know the please don't go with
drug dogs a very good reason to not
really
don't go mental remember in your music
Russells anymore yeah exactly
that works in a perfectly good
functioning village for about a week or
two you know I mean and the police seem
to be able to walk around absolutely
fine using one everyone's eyes is very
slim something is going to attack - yeah
yeah it is much more pleasant now I'm
not advocating the practice that people
do get I would not acknowledge you
nobody you get attacked in the comments
for advocating the use of law obviously
in his regulation yeah and that's what
you're saying is not I'm saying we
should save lives and reduce harm and
one great point that you made is if
people out there in previous interviews
in you said if you don't care about you
know them that side of things of the
care of people and want people to not be
in such a bad way that they're at the
you know at the end of the form of a
gangster all the time one the next fix
don't care about the money because it
costs a lot more money to police these
people and to jail these people than it
does to care for them and nurse them but
the Health's sure if you are one of
those people who cares about the money
now it's may correctly you're an [__]
okay though that's quite interesting as
well isn't it actually there is it
there's still gonna be a big stigma
around drugs which you again take a
generation or a feud to get rid of
argument you're also saying something
here that it will create a massive
revenue stream for the government and
you can tax it and yeah absolutely I
mean that the amount of taxes cream
brought it in in the United States and
those those states whereas legalizes ups
enormous
morally suicide rates are going down in
the states where marijuana has been
legalized as well yeah I'm there is less
opioid overdoses in those states as well
which is also very interesting I think
hmm a lot of statistics ready to back
you up yeah that'd be pretty evidence is
all on the side of reform you know I can
debate anyone yeah
anyone publicly not sure if I'm a your
watcher will turn up now all those yeah
because they evidences on our side only
once it's a policy to follow evidence
it's just not too much to ask of any
politician I don't think well we're only
police officers who came to you after
the book came out and maleic I'm not
really happy put that in or you know
disagreed without your role or anything
like that it's all on the book came out
I was public enemy number one to the
covert policing well because I was
talking about it I was campaigning about
it since the books come out I've had
enormous amount of support so many
people have contacted me in fact we've
got several new members at leap UK who
are ex undercover cops who are saying
you'd same things were on my mind
bullying it's fantastic I'm too modest
if you had to do things such as have sex
with people or take drugs while
undercover never had to have sex with
anyone definitely would never have done
that for ethical reasons
I did have to take drugs only smoke come
up a few times I had to take amphetamine
once which was pretty that stupidly made
myself out to be a concert or
amphetamine and got myself into a bit of
a sticky situation observer users which
was horrendous how do you make yourself
out to be as you in your own words
connoisseur I was just you know I love
my love for you to become would see I
just talked about you know a lot some
really good speed and under like they
Madame Fatima let me taxies those kind
of things mate or quarter bluff yeah
well we did is he had me present and it
was normal occurred like normal speed is
about five percent pure that was forty
percent pure o2 and I was up to three
nights it was horrendous so I just mind
you my house has never been so tidy
yeah yeah afterthought speed makes you
very much on how horrible we ever
worried to eat do drugs with them and
then you'd sort of drop of God well I
didn't do that it didn't take drugs very
often and there's really a last resort
kind of thing yeah I mean I thought not
terms every thoughts about I mean is
tomorrow the spirit could out there is
possible old yeah
ha Mississippi sisters need to go yeah
someone was asking what is the worst
thing you had to do in order to keep
your identity secret mmm now now means
lots of people are manipulated there's
no one particular thing I had to do I
appreciate that about you though that
you seem sort of yes or proud of what
you did but equally when was feeble when
we people you saw I've had a bit of
guilt about that because I think a lot
of people wouldn't I'm not proud of what
I did I mean I'm proud of the personal
development I got out of it and I'm
pleased that some nasty people were put
in prison but overall I'm not proud of
the work at all because the bigger day I
significantly caused more harm than good
significantly and did you get much
support from app for the from the police
so it friends you know you received
counseling on madness or anything like
that or is that not the kind of nowhere
weekly counseling once the area was
crying I can say by the slogan is
fiercely is like oh yeah they really
look tough so yeah no I mean I had PTSD
and they don't that isn't understanding
at all right yes dear the end I was a
bit of a mess and but the people don't
the son Peter do you feel I mean we
could talk for a long time on this as
well but you have what soldiers or PTSD
and the service Wonder Woman do you feel
like this still a stigma about that yeah
I think there is but it's decreasing
there in significantly less so but
there's still people don't stand a
enough another thing there should be
more discussion ability to understand it
yeah when you're putting yourself in
very our brains as humans on men to go
through the things like the you begin to
and other people have been through so
when you go through that there needs to
be like aftercare
yeah but oddly enough all the near-death
experiences are hard and there was quite
a few it's not actually those that were
dominating a mind when I was suffering
from PTSD because you have such intense
anxious memories are always existing
only in one memory it was really really
a rendus when you're doing without sleep
but it wasn't the sort of a throw to
anything it was it was the people of
manipulated it was the companies and the
other people I was guilt
yeah yeah firmament moral damage I think
is the phrase right someone asked what
was the closest you ever came to blowing
your color this other
yeah well had someone find the camera
with a very long story though so I had a
gangsta find the camera that he probably
have to read Murray little problem
because every mark I was longer become
like him a lot but in the book Dorian a
Latina Boyer not-so-silent Lea so I read
a lot them I found a camera they found
they found the camera and yeah that I
almost got run over with a car who was
it was very touch-and-go siphonophore
Camilla yeah so there's a pair that one
we used by the book here and there was
Karen and Michael she's some couple of
questions at the end look quite funny
who would make a better detective
Lawrence O'Brien oh well I mean you've
got a great attention to detail which we
can't stand you in good stead but you've
got such a an open sort of likable I'm
not saying you're not likable or you've
got that sort of instant connection
people would be an advantage until so
how about hybrid baby yeah baby yeah
baby yeah baby yeah all right half and
that comes out on the pockets alone I
think the only reason I'd give the edge
to Lawrence is because it I feel
conspicuous know the fact that you're a
lot more less confrontational than me so
I think I'm very good up until that
until you say confrontational because if
someone got me face but I think I find
it very hard to just brush it off as I
think you'd be good at that yeah but
then I don't know because I thought you
can train yourself if you know again if
you know there's gonna be rewards from
not being confrontational back for
different thing your real life is if
your confrontation about you tend to get
a reward because look at where you sort
of play the long game I suppose in this
respect yeah you're much more
manipulative than I am
following the fancy at the relay to me
if those women on the case do I have to
shag around and get interrupted morally
I'm willing to do average me alone does
he ever get so friendly with criminals
that he sympathizes with hermano UKaid
already did you ever get in touch with
any of them after you retired or
anything like that I know I know I
haven't although what one day I D hope
to do that and an interesting one
particular person I got friendly with a
drug were to come a drug worker
contacted me to let me know that that
particular person is alive and well and
that was that was amazing to hear
actually it was just so good to hear
that this particular person in Leicester
was was a Lobby mile so one final
question buddy how would you like to be
remembered I don't like to be ruined
that it's a big question but I like ask
people there because I think it says a
lot about people how bad suppose I'd
like to be remembered as someone who
brought the truth to people and helped
contribute in a small way to the ending
of the war on drugs well I hope you got
we just tried to get me because I think
you're doing a really good job too much
thanks very much for coming on Neil
Thank You Tricia I mean yeah we'll leave
the link to the book in the description
below I'm shall be a croc in read if
you've enjoyed this wiki well you have
frocking you enjoyed this video click
the like button to subscribe thanks for
watching and we'll see ya